measles is one of the most contagious of
all viruses 90% of people who were
exposed and not vaccinated will get it
the virus lives in the nose and throat
it's spread by breathing coughing
sneezing or coming in close personal
contact it can hang suspended in the air
or on a surface for up to two hours
meaning you can catch it by just walking
into a room one person can infect as
many as 18 others the virus incubates
for seven to fourteen days then the
first sign of measles begins high fever
cough runny noses and red and watery
eyes after several days a rash erupts
red flat spots appear on the face and
then spread downward to the neck body
arms leg and feet an infected person is
contagious from four days before to four
days after the rash breaks after ear
infections in diarrhea are common
complications more severe cases can lead
to pneumonia or encephalitis a swelling
of the brain which can cause permanent
brain damage one or two in every
thousand children with measles will die
but measles is preventable with a
vaccine that is 97% effective measles
vaccination started in 1963 in the US
and the virus was declared eliminated in
2000 that means it no longer originates
here still there are about 20 million
cases a year worldwide that means an
unvaccinated person can bring it into
the country while traveling which is how
a current outbreak may have started at
Disneyland the US has seen 102 cases in
at least 14 states in January of this
year alone a rate that has health
officials on high alert